widerstand widerstand das rufen die
wütenden sogenannten querdenker gestern
abend in münchen
impfen macht frei steht sogar auf einem
plakat und das erinnert an dunkels der
nazizeit
mehrere hundert gegner der korona
maßnahmen haben unangemeldet in der
innenstadt demonstriert zahlreiche
straßen wurden gesperrt die polizei muss
die innenstadt mit gittern blockieren
unter den demonstranten auch
polizeibekannte reichs bürger und
hooligans die demo bleibt zunächst
friedlich doch gegen 19 uhr eskaliert
die situation
fast 1000 demonstranten marschieren
plötzlich im gleichschritt los die
polizei versucht vergeblich sie zu
stoppen schreien und pfeifen ziehen die
demonstranten zum platz der opfer des
nationalsozialismus dann greift die
polizei hart durch traurige bilanz 28
festnahmen unter anderem wegen
beleidigungen oder körperverletzungen
demonstrationen eskalieren also beinahe
täglich trotzdem sagt der neue
bundeskanzler olaf scholz gestern in
seiner ersten regierungserklärung dass
hier viel ist ja zurzeit von der
angeblichen spaltung unserer
gesellschaft die rede dazu stelle ich
fest unsere gesellschaft ist nicht
gespalten also ich finde das ist
schwachsinn ja es gibt
selbstverständlich eine spaltung ich
denke schon dass es eine gewisse
spaltung gibt also eine gewisse spaltung
ist schon da querdenker gehen auf die
straße demonstrieren radikalisieren sich
wenden geweihter veranstalten fackeln
leisten widerstand gegen die polizei
dazu drohbriefe an den bundestag es gibt
sogar morddrohungen ein opfer sachsens
ministerpräsident michael kretschmer
razzien finden statt bei den menschen
die den politiker mutmaßlich ermorden
wollten unsere gesellschaft ist nicht
gespalten sind sie sich herr
bundeskanzler
fest steht die angriffe und drohungen
werden immer radikaler getroffen hat es
unter anderem einige politiker im
deutschen bundestag sie bekam drohbriefe
bestückt mit fleischbällchen und dem
droht texte heißt es das fleisch ist mit
ausstrahlenden cupid 19 viren und mit
zyklon b durchsicht der widerstand gegen
die impfung und die maßnahmen wird
blutig und unappetitlich so das zitat
zyklen und babys haben die nazis in den
vernichtungslagern eingesetzt eine
drohung die an widerwärtigkeit nicht zu
überbieten ist sachsens
ministerpräsident kretzschmar wie gesagt
bekam sogar morddrohungen dazu hat er
sich folgendermaßen geäußert
ich bin froh dass der rechtsstaat heute
im freistaat sachsen gezeigt hat wie
wehrhaft er ist bedrohungen gegen
amtspersonen seines bürgermeister
gemeinderäte landräte aber auch
gegenüber wissenschaftlern und
journalisten sind nicht hinnehmbar
werden nicht geduldet und werden mit
aller kraft verfolgt wir haben in der
staatsregierung entschieden auch
zusätzliches personal für den kampf
gegen extremisten zu mobilisieren die
hausdurchsuchungen die heute
stattgefunden haben sind angewiesen
worden weil man einen dringenden
verdacht hat dass dort auch straftaten
eine rolle spielen könnten bin froh
darüber dass diese entschiedenheit
gezeigt worden ist und jeder soll wissen
dass man im freistaat sachsen und in der
bundesrepublik deutschland
selbstverständlich seine meinung sagen
kann dass man selbstverständlich auch
sagen kann was einem nicht gefällt aber
wenn gewalt ins spiel kommt ist schluss
ist eine grenze überschritten
überschritten die von uns nicht geduldet
wird und so wie wir das in dieser stelle
tun sind wir auch bereit an anderen
stellen zugreifen und darüber hinaus bin
ich dankbar dass die neue
bundesregierung auch erklärt hat dass
sie hats
falschinformationen und ganz billige art
der zersetzung das zerstören des
vertrauens in institutionen auch in den
messenger diensten in zukunft stärker
und mit nachdruck verfolgen will das
brauchen wir auch dieses instrument ist
notwendig für eine wehrhafte demokratie
auch saarlands ministerpräsident tobias
hans zeigt sich entsetzt über die
gewalteskalation und fordert ein hartes
eingreifen des rechtsstaates es ist
einfach entsetzlich wie wir im moment
einer farm auch der debattenkultur
erleben und das führt letztendlich dann
auch zu solchen
gewaltandrohungen das ist nicht zu
akzeptieren
hier muss der rechtsstaat mit aller
härte eingreifen und ich glaube dass
hier längstens eine grenze überschritten
ist es muss jetzt gehandelt werden wir
müssen denen die nach dem leben von
familien letztendlich ja auch trachten
eben sehr klar zeigen wir werden das
nachverfolgen
deutschland also nicht gespalten eine
aussage von olaf scholz die bild live
chef claus strunz bei unserem talk
format viertel nach acht gestern abend
nicht nachvollziehen konnte olaf scholz
hat festgestellt unsere gesellschaft ist
nicht gespalten und da möchte man ihm
zurufen herr scholz wo leben ist die
eigentlich in welcher blase befinden sie
sich offenbar in einer blase in der nur
sie selbst leben in einer art scholz
blase denn deutschland ist so
zerstritten ist zerrüttet so gespalten
wie noch nie zuvor jedenfalls noch nie
seit ich mich für politische
zusammenhänge interessieren und die
spaltung geht in alle bereiche unseres
zusammenlebens eltern streiten sich
darüber ob die kinder geimpft werden
sollen oder nicht lehrer streiten
darüber wie das mit der masken pflicht
ist menschen geraten in bussen
aneinander und werden handgreiflich
kolleginnen und kollegen tuscheln und
sagen guck mal dass der kollege vom
leben büro der ist doch bestimmt nicht
geimpft und war der eigentlich schon bei
seinem test in bester blog mag man hier
überall wo man hinschaut ist in
deutschland spaltung nur uns olaf stellt
fest es gibt keine spaltung in unserer
gesellschaft und das ist mehr als nur
ein schlimmer vorfahrt zum anfang
eine regierungszeit das ist riskant es
wirkt arrogant und es ist in jedem fall
ignorant
doch was hat dafür gesorgt dass die
radikalisierung zunimmt das wollen wir
jetzt vom politologen werner patzelt
wissen er war früher professor an der tu
dresden guten tag herr patzelt einen
schönen guten tag herr patzelt sie
galten während der proteste gegen die
migrationswelle 2015 2016 zunächst vor
allem in ostdeutschland als päda
verstehe sind sich jetzt ein querdenker
verstehe ich habe damals zumindest
verstanden worum es geht und dass das
was auf der straße sich tat lediglich
ein indikator dafür ist dass es in der
gesellschaft brodelt und tatsächlich ich
verstehe jetzt auch sehr wohl warum es
zu diesen hässlichen szenen und
entsetzlichen auswüchsen kommt es hat
ein nennenswerter teil der bevölkerung
unserer gesellschaft unserem start
unserer politiker schafft innerlich
gekündigt und nimmt alles mögliche zum
anlass diese entwendung dieses gekündigt
haben dieses dagegen seien möglichst
drastisch zum ausdruck zu bringen
deswegen sollte man sich nicht der
hoffnung hingeben wenn die korona
pandemie nächstes jahr hoffentlich
überwunden ist würde dieser inneren
verwendung dieser lauernde sprungbereit
die protestbereitschaft aufhören und in
der tat man muss diese tiefen schichten
verstehen und dass sich nicht auf das
oberflächen geschehen konzentrieren so
als ob wenn man den leuten klarmachen
dass carola gefährlich ist und impfungen
helfen diese ganze protest verschwinden
würde aber warum dann dieses aggressive
radikale verhalten man kann auch ganz
normal demonstrieren nehmen sie uns mal
mit in diese kopf der querdenker
man kann vernünftig miteinander reden
aber das setzt voraus dass man den
eindruck hat die anderen würden auch
vernünftig mit einem selbst reden wollen
wer glaubt dass man ihm eh nicht zuhört
dass man ihn geschwindelt dass man ihn
betrügen will dass man seine freiheit
einschränken will wie das die korona
politik kritiker tun der meint dass der
alte aus der studentin revolution
bekannte satz jetzt wieder einmal
anzuwenden sei nämlich wer sich nicht
wehrt der lebt verkehrt oder die
probleme des systems und das system ist
das problem und in dieser denkweise
greifen solche leute sogar zum artikel
20 4 des grundgesetzes wonach jeder ein
widerstandsrecht hat wenn dieser staat
in eine diktatur verkehrt wird das ist
dann krauses denken aber an jeder
psychiater wird ihnen sagen dass es sehr
leichte wege sind die zu den schlimmsten
verwirrungen führen wie kann man diese
wege versperren herr patzelt wir haben
es vorhin gesagt da ist drohung dabei
mit zyklon b beispielsweise dass die
nazis in vernichtungslagern eingesetzt
haben also ganz klare
rechtsextremistische tendenzen oder
unter wanderungen bei diesen prozessen
reichs bürger sind dabei
verschwörungstheoretiker wie kann man
diesen weg von dem sie sprechen
versperren
kurzfristig wird man sagen müssen lässt
sich wenig tun wenn es einmal so weit
gekommen ist dass sich leute mit freude
daran öffentlich protestieren mit
abscheulichen aktionen in der
öffentlichkeit begeben lässt sich
kurzfristig nichts tun das was man
machen kann ist jene kriminellen recht
rechtsradikalen in diesem fall häufig
netzwerke polizeilich ausfindig zu
machen und sie in den justiz vor
zuzuführen und mit tatsächlich ab
strecke abschreckenden strafen
klarzumachen dass sich der staat hier
nicht auf der nase herumtanzen lässt und
dass wir unsere freiheiten zusichern
gedenken man muss aber langfristig
strategien ergreifen und zu denen gehört
dass wir unseren wechselseitigen
überbietungswettbewerb beim schimpfen
auf politische gegner allesamt aufhören
wir müssen unsere lust in grenzen halten
durch trennstrich leute auszugrenzen
denn jenseits der trends striche
radikalisieren sie sich so wie das die
korona leute tun das heißt langfristig
sollten wir alle zu einem entspannteren
vernünftigeren umgang beim politischen
diskutieren kommen und nicht mehr
unseren ganzen ehrgeiz daran setzen den
anderen als möglich schlimm und böse
idealerweise als nazi darzustellen
apparat aber nicht erzählt keiner will
doch diese leute ausgrenzen sie grenzen
sich doch selber aus das ist bei den
coroner leuten inzwischen so aber noch
die leute die die afd wählern die bei
peggy das demonstriert haben wollten
sich selbst überhaupt nicht aus denn sie
wollten gehör finden es ist halt einfach
eine kette von falschen umgangsweisen
mit politisch andersdenkenden die dazu
geführt hat dass immer mehr leute
überhaupt keine hoffnung mehr haben dass
der staat die gesellschaft die mehrheit
ihnen zuhören würde und deswegen ziehen
sie sich schmollend rotzig in ihre
sonder welten zurück